hallo mein name ist luca und ich hab so
ein format auf meinem kanal bei dem ich
auf videos von zuschauern reagiere und
das mach ich jetzt
hey luca was geht eben science ruhen ich
habe deine frage die kennt eventuell
schon das hormon aus einigen vorherigen
teilen dieser serie locker reagiert
das ist nämlich einfach ein huhn das
sprechen kann
warum heißt es eigentlich horror wurde
das hat überhaupt nichts mit horror zu
tun auf jeden fall hat dieses huhn eine
frage an mich das heißt
das stage is yours fragt mich was auch
über nämlich fragen möchtest und zwar
warum ist denn dieses wunderschöne luca
kissen so flasche nach horror und das
ist auch logisch ich meine das kitzeln
ist dementsprechend so flauschig weil er
ist einfach ein kissen ist was es zu
kaufen gibt es gewinner von de
analysiert gar nicht mehr so lange
abonnent sind auf einem kanal
das war halt echt krank so im dezember
wir waren einer der schnellst wachsenden
kanäle in deutschland
ich habe hier fordere in meinem aufnahme
zimmer alles voll gemacht mit smiley
kissen bewegen drohen also die sind
nicht nur flauschig sondern agiere noch
als absorber kann man mal schauen was
der vorhut noch zu sagen hat damit kann
ich immer direkt einschlafen dankeschön
dafür kann ich nur empfehlen
guck mal da brauche ich gar nicht mehr
selbst promo machen für meinen shop wo
es dieses lauschigen kissen zu kaufen
gibt kann ich nur empfehlen
was die stimme
hund los
flexen war ja bis vor einem tag selber
österreich im skiurlaub und der verlage
auch mega kranken er ich weiß gar nicht
warum tiere zu krank auf schnee abgehen
es ist ja nicht nur bei hunden so
sondern da wo wir waren war auch nebenan
ein alpaka farben und die alpakas
alternativ sind gar nicht klar gekommen
die die waren total verwirrt aber gut
alpakas ein anderes thema aber wo ich
gerade dabei bin meine damen und herren
ich hatte überlegt eventuell bald mal
eine alpaka wanderung zu machen und es
zu bloggen also hätte dir da bock drauf
dass ich so was mache dann lass mein
leid beim video da
jetzt wollen
die leute schon hat sich tomatensaft
maria tomatensaft ist ja damals
entstanden weil es denn mir eine
einwendung geschickt hat wo er einfach
tomatensaft gerufen hat um orten an der
stelle eine ganz große sache uns was
denn du hast mir schon lange nichts mehr
ein geschickt wir brauchen mal neuen
input von dir
guck mal da rede ich gerade bei input
und dann kriege ich hier so ne scheiße
zugesendet
einfach ehrenhaft dass es einfach
doppelt
schon lange nicht mehr gesagt hier
findest du lukas facebook anschaut war
so langweilig und sie ist darauf
eingeschlafen der welt hier meine damen
und herren ich habe es hier oben liegen
ihr könnt es draußen in ihrer
buchhaltung fahrzeug auf den linken der
beschreibung die können sie dann luca
shop gehen und auf das buch klicken dann
könnte es auch glaubt er redete weiter
werde direkt auf amazon ist ein buch in
dem ich und meine mutter das ist super
ich schlag direkt eine seite auf der er
genau sehen wie toll ich malen kann hier
habe ich ein bild beispielsweise für
meine mutter gemacht aber ich habe mich
für einmal geschrieben sondern ich habe
mama geschrieben und ich habe ja einen
alien gemalt also als er hätte nicht
weil buch du kaputt
warum
warum man ist in der schule um zu lernen
meine damen und herren um pünktlich zu
sein um alles mögliche zu lernen über
die deutsche grammatik über die deutsche
rechtschreibung oder mathematik über
fremdsprachen was macht sie
wir schauen sie uns doch mal an es ist
rodelbahn oder was euer tannebaum passt
definitiv nicht in ihre wohnung zwar
auch krank da wo wir jetzt in österreich
im urlaub waren als ich mit meiner
familie die hat ein tannenbaum und ich
gucke die tannenbaum sein und sie so wo
ja gar keinen tannenbaum stellen da gar
kein ding unten sondern der wir hier an
der decke
er hätte hätte komplett besoffen du aber
auch nicht beim nächsten video muss ich
vorher ganz kurz sagen das hat mir eine
userin eingeschickt die sich einfach nur
kurz ein spielt auf dem klavier und in
der in dem tweet hat sie allerdings
gesagt dass beim einspielen ihr hund im
hintergrund gekotzt hat also film ab
habe ich jetzt zwar nicht so ganz gehört
wieder runter gekotzt hat aber anhand
dieser reaktion kann man schon sich
denken dass das passiert ist
wie kann ein video mehr stereotyp
schweiz sein
hey ich mal guckt euch das hier allein
an das willst du diese typischen bilder
die man auf irgend welche postkarten hat
oder irgendwie was krank
einfach krank
ich glaube da muss ich nichts mehr zu
sagen die katze kann tatsächlich besser
klavier spielen als ich
und das könnte derzeit sogar wirklich
der wahrheit entsprechen ich habe mir in
den letzten monaten ja ein bisschen
klavierspielen beigebracht allerdings in
den letzten wochen einfach gar keine
zeit mehr dafür gehabt
so voll traurig eigentlich muss
eigentlich mal wieder anfangen wo wir
aber gerade über musik sprechen meine
damen und herren iaa übergang zum
nächsten video
die fig auf übergänge und qualität in
meinen videos eine zuschauerin hat mir
ein video zugesendet indem sie meint
dass sie selber ein lied geschrieben hat
also selber den text verfasst hat und
ich sollte es mir mal anhalt also film
ab sei warum sagt ich so oft film ab
warum sagt man überhaupt film ab der
film ist an jetzt herr luca ich ein lied
selber geschrieben und sag mal bist du
davon hält
ich muss sagen man kann dem ganzen noch
ein bisschen feiern aber ich habe auf
jeden fall gehabt schon album von einem
natur als siebenter personelle die luke
evans noch mal meine damen und herren
das hochschule zurück
great la wird irgendwie handelt das
ganze video von diesem hohen ich hätte
da noch eine frage darf man eines liebes
lied für dich schreiben
du willst ein liebeslied für mich
schreiben
ja
wer geil liebeslied von
hagen natürlich nur für eins freuen also
ich weiß nicht warum das nun am ende
dann abgeschossen wurde aber die bis vor
augen wenn du wirklich ein liebeslied
machst und das video dann irgendwie
kanal und liebeslied von kraft an dance
oder so dann würde ich sogar darauf
reagieren also just do it just ehrenhaft
freunde immer schön mit instagram pushen
teilte nämlich auf instagram instagram
freunde es fehlen noch um die 50.000
abonnenten dann haben wir die zwei
millionen ich zeige gerade vier aber
zwei millionen hashtag zwei millionen
halo luca
hallo
irgendwie finde ich das sieht ein
bisschen aus wie m rad
jetzt schon bestens kennzeichen nicht
lustig
oh mein gott freunde mir wurde jetzt ja
eine parodie von katja glaser wird story
eingesendet also wir schauen mal von
welchem julia diehl
moorhuhn aber meine damen und herren hat
mich auch schon gefragt ob es ein
liebeslied für mich schreiben darf jetzt
haben wir hier die katja kaminski
parodie also vielleicht kann horn ja
singen wir gehen da mal komplett
unvoreingenommen jetzt rein und das
video ich bin ein
ich bin einen hund mein lifestyle ist
gesund
scheiße aber freunde wir wollen ja gar
nicht zu krass urteilen vielleicht wird
das video noch besser ich meine
barkawitz vorgedacht lauf zu beginn okay
das ist kompletter scheiß zum ende war
es dann auch scheiße aber nicht so krass
ist gesund bist weil du immer noch
scheiße ich frage mich ob honda auch ein
feature katrin also wir schauen jetzt
mal weiter 100.000 euro in der braunen
gucci bauchtasche cofresco chef manny
jimi blue horror huhn hat er jetzt ein
feature mit money boy also aber wie das
bei feature so ist ist nur der
mittelplatz dann irgendwie von einem
anderen und das heißt das ende sollte er
jetzt wieder vom horror- und sein also
freunde phil man diesmal grad an ich
trage nur noch 100 peter kohl und hunde
bild
daher will ich gar nichts mehr zu sagen
auch geiles video freunde wisst ihr für
solche videos mache ich noch dieses
format einfach damit ich euer talent
zeigen kann oder auch nicht
du hast deinen hund geklaut das ist erst
mal eine straftat aber ich glaube das
ist ironie deswegen lasse ich das jetzt
mal plötzlich jetzt nicht der polizei
kompresse glück gehabt
es liegt schnee bei dir das ist ja
klasse ich weiß auch in österreich da
lagen eineinhalb meter schnee
aber gut wir schauen uns wenn wir mal
weiter anders schnee oder er kokain
dagegen kopf aus
ein lieber junge ich glaube
die sind wie kokain aussieht ich kann
dir erwärmt ist nun ein buch empfiehlt
uns war das core crafter muss da siehst
du dass ich nicht so eine verstörende
kindheit hatte etwa malta wer kann sich
benehmen wie man will man kann sich
schnell gegen den kopfschmerz erkannten
kokain aber wenn man sagt immer wieder
schafft dann ist man in meinen augen so
blöd
ja
luca du stinkst
geil freut mich dass so was dann das
letzte video ist ich hatte gerade mein
mikro in der hand
das war es jetzt in familie meine damen
und herren wenn es euch gefallen hat und
ich öfter luca geht hoch laden soll dann
las man fetten leid bei dem video da und
wenn ihr möchte dass ich bald mal ein
alpaka wanderung machen und das ganze
blog
sonst würde ich das video an dieser
stelle ist allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren es ist mein letztes
video im jahr 2017 heute ist nämlich der
31 12
das heißt ich würde sagen sie sind es am
ersten ersten 2018 wieder und bis dahin
habe ich auf jeden fall noch eine
wichtige messe brauche ich und zwar das
video das war's jetzt ihr vom video ihr
könnt jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken hier findet ihr zwei anderen
videos und wenn ich schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auch die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen